cette semaine l'organisation
météorologique mondiale annoncé que
l'année 2018 avait été la quatrième
année la plus chaude à être enregistrés
donc comme 2015 2016 2017 dans ce triste
palmarès des années aux températures les
plus élevées et ce matin on va parler de
ça mais également des développements
dans la recherche concernant les
changements climatiques notamment la
couleur des océans qui risque de changer
renou manuguerra gagne est avec moi pour
en parler bonjour renault mais bonjour
d'abord d'où viennent ces chiffres
concernant les années les plus chaudes
ce sont des chiffres qui ont été
compilées à partir de millions de
données qui venait de relever cette
élite océanique météorologiques de la
nasa mais aussi de quatre autres grandes
agences à travers les états unis
l'europe et le japon etc des données qui
confirme d'abord que les températures
ont augmenté de 1 degré celsius depuis
la fin de l'ère industrielle que le gros
de cette eau cela est arrivé depuis les
années 50
et comme on dit que les quatre dernières
années ont été les plus chaudes qu'on
ait enregistré jusqu'à maintenant c'est
pas les plus chaudes que la terre ait
vécu dans toute son histoire le climat
c'est quelque chose qui évolue
constamment
mais à cause des activités humaines et
de la production assez importante de gaz
à effet de serre qu'on fait constamment
c'est cette température et la demande
beaucoup plus rapidement aujourd'hui
qu'elle devrait le faire normalement et
cette roche mais c'est ce qui accélère
le rythme auquel on voit les événements
météo extrêmes comme les vagues de
chaleur les vagues de froid les
sécheresses et les inondations c'est un
peu un désert on voit ici tous les
extrêmes mais en plus de bouleverser
tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur des
océans justement c'est ça il ya deux
études parues cette semaine qui manque
les effets des changements climatiques
sur les océans oui ces deux études qui
sont parues dans des magazines du groupe
nature
la première porte sur la vitesse de la
fonte des calottes glaciaires parce que
beaucoup de chercheurs qui travaillent à
essayer d'évaluer la vitesse de cette
fonte pour voir à quel rythme ça va
influencer la hausse du niveau de la mer
mais y en a d'autres qui veulent plutôt
déterminer comment la fonte des glaces
peut affecter les températures mais
aussi les courants océaniques donc celui
qui est vraiment été suivie dans une de
ses études ses dents du haut de ses
études c'est le golf stream c'est le
courant qui amène l'eau chaude de
l'équateur jusque jusqu'aux dents et
l'attitude plus un peu plus nordique
dans l'atlantique
qui par exemple permet à l'europe
d'avoir un climat plus doux alors qu'on
est que l'amérique nous on en amérique
du nord alors qu'on est pourtant la même
latitude et sans courant qui est
essentielle pour la vie marine et pour
le climat général est comment ça modifie
les courants mais normalement en
arrivant près de l'arctique et du
groenland ce courant d'eau chaude l'eau
va se refroidir votre charge en oxygène
redescendre dans les fonds marins faire
une boucle est retournée comme ça vers
l'équateur mais la chaleur plus élevé en
même temps que la quantité vraiment
important d'eau douce qui est déversée
par la fonte des glaciers autour de
l'arctique et du groenland ça ça vaut
vraiment chant perturbé tout ce
processus et les chercheurs estiment que
une portion assez important de ce
mécanisme pourrait perdre jusqu'à 15% de
toute sa force de au cours de la
deuxième moitié du xxième siècle
est ce qu'en ville soit ça s'en vient
c'est en parlons là c'est pour ça que
les chercheurs disent qu'il ya qu'il
faut qu'on agisse rapidement qu'il faut
être con à dire quand il le fameux
chiffres faux qu'on agisse dans les
douze ans et c'est un de ces raisons là
et surtout ça risque d'augmenter le
risque d'événements extrêmes en amérique
et en amérique du nord et en europe
et puis il ya une deuxième étude qui
affirme que la couleur des océans va
changer comme on explique sans ça c'est
quelque chose d'assez surprenant mais
qui est quand même vraiment
problématique tout dépendamment de où on
se trouve on l'eau pourraient devenir
beaucoup plus bleue cristalline ou
beaucoup plus verte brunâtre et ça c'est
un changement qu on vote d'abord voir
principalement par satellite et qui se
l'est qui lie aux concentrations de
phytoplancton dans l'eau seul
phytoplancton c'est les algues
microscopiques sont à la base de toute
la chaîne alimentaire marine est la
couleur de l'océan varie en fonction la
présence de ces algues plus en fait l'on
va devenir de plus en plus opaque à
mesure que leur concentration augmente
mais le phytoplancton c'est quelque
chose de fragile l'yonne il y en existe
plusieurs espèces et qui ont toutes des
besoins différents en terme de
température et d'éléments nutritifs et
avec l' or justement que des
températures et les changements au
niveau des courants océaniques
mais certains mécanismes qui pourraient
être importants pour leur survie qui
pourrait changer
ah oui quel genre de mécanisme mais tous
les plans dont un cycle comme je disais
tantôt l'eau chaude remontent à la
surface sa charge en exonère descend
vers le fond et cette espèce de boucle
perpétuelle ça brasse les éléments
nutritifs ray et c'est ce qui a aidé à
nourrir le phytoplancton
mais si l'autre surface reste chaude
tout le temps
ce brassage va arrêter le plancton va
plus de nourriture et vaud soit mourir
soit être obligés de se déplacer
c'est ce qui fait que on va se retrouver
que des eaux plus transparente dans
l'est dans les océans au niveau de
l'équateur par exemple mais en même
temps ce qui est problématique c'est que
tous les poissons qui dépendent de ces
plantes de ce plancton là pour leur
survie mais où seront soit mourir de
faim sous être forcé de se déplacer donc
il y aura un bouleversement au niveau de
la chaîne alimentaire
à ces endroits là dans d'autres endroits
on va voir une plutôt une explosion de
la production de plancton à cause de
l'ajustement des changements de
températures qui vont devenir plus
propices à leur croissance et les
chercheurs les chercheurs estiment qu'en
gros si rien n'est fait pour ralentir
les changements climatiques au cours des
prochaines années
mais c'est 50% des océans mondiaux qui
vont voir ce genre de changement la cie
2100 donc vraiment les connaissances
raffinement matière d'impact ce soit
plus plus les années passent plus on a
des nouvelles études qui permettent de
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe est ce
donc on va savoir quel point les
températures vont changer puis rendu là
bas c'est vraiment aux décideurs et aux
citoyens de voir comment on peut
ralentir la progression des changements
mais voilà parce que c'est loin d'être
rassurant tout ça
effectivement si vous courez 9 les airs
avant